hey guys welcome back to brand-new to
Rebecca I'm wearing it today we're gonna
be continuing our usual series whenever
a new event comes out and that's how to
get the loot the fastest within the
event mode so let's get started with
that so as always the newest event
raining Inferno gave some nice limited
time cosmetic glue and weapons like the
new raining infernal effect new ornament
new battle outfit and a whole new set of
weapons for every character if you just
want to know how to get it you could
skip to the time on screen because I
just want to explain this very important
thing very clearly
these aren't permanently lootable but
they are permanently kept meaning you
only have a limited time which is
basically until the event is over on
August 30th to loot these exact items
that I just showed you but if you happen
to loot these during the event time you
get to keep them forever even after the
event is over so just to explain one
more time these items are only lootable
for a small amount of time like I said
until August 30th but if you do happen
to loot them you will keep them forever
and if you do not loot that specific
item you cannot get it back until the
next time this event comes back which at
this time we have no clue and that will
even happen because that is a year from
now now that that is over let's talk
about the best method to do this so
first off we can eliminate all the PvP
game mode since it's easier to kill a
I've in mystical players everyone knows
that and the best for all of these is
brawl AI you cannot get the new effects
ornament or outfit from duel AI because
it's too easy to farm and the devs don't
want that although I am unsure about the
weapon parts though I don't have proved
myself of getting weapons from duel AI
but other people in the past from the
past events have said that this also
works in do live just to get the weapon
parts so you can try duel a I but
personally if it doesn't work then just
go to brawl AI since that is the fastest
mode some people may argue that Dominion
is longer but roughly gives the same
amount of loot as so it really doesn't
matter but in the 5 Dominion matches
that I played to test this I actually
got less loot than in my 5 brawl matches
it could just be orangey but still I
would rather stick with brawl anyway in
terms of speed my average brawl AI
matches were around 2 minutes and 4
seconds but my longest being 2 minutes
and 30 seconds just a quick recap you
want to be playing brawl AI to get the
new ornament battle outfit effect and
weapon set now you can only get the
weapons set for the character that you
play so if I place you go key I'm only
going to get you go key weapons but for
the ornament effect and battle outfit it
does not matter what character you play
because it's going to be RNG on what
type of
of those three that I just mentioned you
get and for the character which is a lot
of grind time so if you're looking
specifically for the weapon then you
want to play with the character you want
the weapon for so yeah guys that's gonna
be the end of the video hopefully you
guys did enjoy hopefully this also
helped you out just a little bit more
with this event let me know how you guys
are enjoying this event so far I
personally been playing a lot of the
infernal Dominion go mode I'm absolutely
loving this event like I said in one of
my previous videos it's not my favorite
event but it's definitely up there on
the top three yeah like I said it's
going to be the end of the video like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe for new
I cover the informational side of
foreigner that being balance changes
hero updates how to guides tips tricks
leaks all that good stuff and my two
most recent videos will be on screening
if you guys don't want to check that out
with that guys hope every yesterday I
think of Orcs in the video and peace out
[Music]
[Music]